mon père était un grand homme un héros
comme on dit
c'est le monde n'a pas toujours besoin
d'un autre héros
quelquefois il a besoin dans monstres
mon prince semble préoccupe
le sultan se préparent au combat
il veut un millier de jeunes gens dans
son armée
compris votre fils
cours faire ta mère ne regardez pas
tu peux pas me protéger je trouverai un
moyen
j'attends ici depuis une éternité
l'arrivée d'un homme aussi puissant que
toi
désires tu obtenu le pouvoir de détruire
mes ennemis et de sauver ma famille
beurre
bois dracula
yoyo là
mais que tu arrives tu
je suis ce que redoutent les hommes
affronteront autre chose
voilà des boutiques en lui
voyez jouer convient parce que vous
pouvez vous pas
parce que je me suis sacrifié pour vous
sow
n'oublie jamais j'y suis désormais